the East Palestine did I pronounce that
right I think so train derailment is
likely just one of many intentionally
orchestrated attacks manufacturing
plants chicken hatcheries Etc with the
goal of destabilizing our society haha
yeah I would say no but I thought you
would have said yes I
am open to yes however I lean no I never
ascribed to malice that which is equally
explained by incompetence and stupidity
I do think there's something going on
now which is as the Boomers are retiring
Boomers for all their flaws did have
some basic kind of professional
competence and Millennials don't have
that at all Millennials don't know a
damn thing about anything in terms of
practical skills I don't and I certainly
don't you know look I mean this is my
job is I drink and read these cards and
so as that as that starts to change
you're seeing I think some more of these
industrial type accidents